p
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
un couloir quand tu étais au pays du
joug nazi écoute héros gaffeur qui
t'avait mauvais rémy s'est mis en tête
de faire du tricot
depuis ce matin j'ai poussé 240 olol
journée afin de respirer de la poussière
des habitations à tous pour cette
poussée à deux partout et j'ai encore
trois ans qu'on allait allouer au besoin
avec leurs souffrances et ça continue on
à tomber en poussière
piquée au but attention aux petites
situant rue mais un mauvais jour et
aucune grosse écharpe de laine autour du
cou je vais chercher ce qu'ils font
montgobert d2 dépendant du le top c'est
la boutière est moine est c'était chaud
de l'aisne en place et ainsi tu te crées
4 est une belle écharpe ou recevant
revers hasard en place comme tu dis ça
parce que tu es courageuse je te connais
tu it is not moi t'expliquer ne bouge
pas sinon tu vas tout embrouiller il
rend duré longtemps seuls deux joueurs
furent le temps de faire la pilote
téthys lève les bras et lui bras tu vas
tout temps mais les mobiles en goudron
glock ou moi j'ai toujours la même chose
le cra kaka veut voir titus et quitus
est introuvable
regardez autour de vous le verrez disent
tu vas branché nié tout est dit de
regarder autour de vous
sur deux mois est sûre de moi mais je ne
vois que toi a prédit le garder
c'est un entre-deux tours d'horizon mais
je ne vois que les colonnes qui
tournoient veuves et le tournis qui
s'empare de moi où je vais févier j'ai
la tête qui tourne
petit tour de qui tout cas senti
pourtant même souvent nous le croyons à
l'avenir allait bientôt a fait tiquer
[Musique]
et alors lécher le gagne eh bien je vais
les chercher ses motifs et ou de ce
palais chez moi
c'est beau un site au musée et sa
tournée où s'était joué pour moi ça et
sur mosca me l'avait caché ils nous
tuent tous ces mots ce cas moi je les
casser ça donne ça y est reparti de zéro
point à cette amie lisa il faut comme
oscars vient de voir ses joues
émerveillé est-ce que c'est périlleux
mosca whittier en paroisse de tourner
autour
tu vas te tirer de là aller marche
arrière et en avant pour la balle saint
lambert
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
hier à becker la voix thierry attitude
j'étais sur le point de perdre haleine
mon dieu c'est le grand yaka le croyais
à cames appel excuse-moi titus et bercy
bercy bercy un mot qu'on ne te sens pas
ou qui va m'aider à me sortir de là
mais voilà pistolet aux marrons du feu
bref on défend mollement et après après
c'est une autre histoire
[Musique]